now to ew's entertainer of the year
issue which this year features
six groundbreaking cover stars including
dan and eugene levy
i don't know what entertainer of 2020
actually is i'm hoping that's a good
thing
it means we're the absolute best you can
be in terms of entertaining and we're so
much better than everybody else
well they've certainly earned their
bragging rights with shit's creek
dominating pop culture this year and
earning nine primetime emmys i said when
we started the show uh
six years ago i said why don't we shoot
for being entertainers of the year
when this whole thing is uh is done and
it only took you six years to fulfill
that dream the canadian duo are in great
company alongside other honorees
including kerry washington
and the mandalorian star pedro pascal
it's very hard to identify
an accomplishment that i would be
particularly proud of this year because
we've all been experiencing on many
levels
of a similar thing the actor gets pretty
emotional looking back on how the global
lockdown
impacted his own life this year i was
alone
i had to do it on my own and gradually
sort of like carve out a very very
specific
and responsible bubble and so
[Applause]
the friends the friends that i that got
me through it
are absolutely everything to me the
magazine also honors comedian sasha
baron cohen
as well as the late chadwick boseman
with a look at his legacy on and off
screen
and taylor swift rounds out the pack of
cover stars but the magazine
is holding her issue until later this
month